We are asked, what time is it?
So we first want to look at the
hour hand, which is a shorter
hand here and see
where it is pointing.
And it is pointing
right at seven.
So we've just crossed
the seventh hour.
So the hour is seven.
And then we look at the minute
hand, which is the longer hand.
And this minute hand is pointing
straight up, right at the 12.
So this means the
12, when you think
of minutes, that's zero
minutes past the hour.
And then each number
represents five more minutes.
So this is right at 7:00.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do a few more of these.
Where is the hour hand?
So this hour hand,
you might say,
hey, this looks closer to
eight than it is to seven,
but the key is to realize
that it has passed seven
and it hasn't gotten
quite to eight yet.
So we're still in
the seventh hour.
So the hour is seven.
Notice, these hands go
in a clockwise direction.
So just past seven hasn't
gotten to eight yet.
So the hour is seven.
And when we want to think
about the minutes, remember,
we start at the top
of the clock, that's
zero minutes past the hour.
And then we can count
by fives all the way
to where the minute hand is.
So 0, 5, 10, 15, 20,
25, 30, 35, 40, 45.
We're 45 minutes past the hour.
So it's 7:45.
Let's do a couple more.
So where's the hour hand?
Well it's between
the one and the two,
but the key is to realize
that it's going clockwise,
it's passed the one, and
it's about to get to two.
So it's still in the first hour.
So the hour is still one.
And then the minutes, we just
have to count from 0 by fives.
So 0, 5, 10, 15, 20,
25, 30, 35, 40, 45.
It's 1:45 PM.
Let's do one more.
So here, once again, hour
hand is between 1 and 2.
So it's past one, it
hasn't gotten to two yet.
So we're still in
the first hour.
And then the minutes,
well, we start at 12.
That's zero minutes
past the hour.
0, 5, 10, 15.
So it is 1:15.
Let's do even one more.
So this one the hour
hand is exactly at two.
And the minute hand
is exactly at 12.
So that means we're zero
minutes past the hour.
So it's zero minutes
past the hour.